for some reason i always feel pressure
to leave in the uk yeah
or like just drink like not sit down and
eat oh yeah i have this pressure that's
like
drink don't you're not here to eat right
because like when you go with your
your friends to the pub i'm always that
[ __ ] he's like i'm getting a meal
yeah because it's just it's just really
inconvenient because you're there with
like a table for the pints
yeah yeah and then there's this guy who
just orders like a three-course meal and
you're like where are we meant to fit
this
i don't give a [ __ ] i got to hold albies
i would like slowly nudge the 12
beers out of the way to make room for my
like extravagant curry from weather
spoons
and the tables like down here you're
like this
is like bombing out do you do you like
pubs in the uk
yeah i love them in london i thought
london had great pubs i don't know i
really don't like pubs pubs
pubs are the one thing about the uk that
i like anytime i go out the uk i'm like
yes this is a much better drinking
establishment than a pub
because it's just i don't know what it
is about pubs in the uk i just find it
so [ __ ] depressing
because yeah it depends it depends which
one do you go to london has
a ton of like pubs that are like really
lively and
really great atmosphere but they're also
equally as i mean you guys took me to
one uh it was like a gaming hub right
that's shut down wasn't it oh really
yeah that pub was a mess there yeah i
wouldn't i wouldn't even call it i
wouldn't even call it
that was like a gaming bar but like the
dirtiest gaming box
yeah what was it called again meltdown
meltdown it was like
a gaming bar with like five pcs one
dirty old wii u no it wasn't even a wii
u
we a wii u and like they would be like
the same people who would hog the pcs
and there was no limit or anything so
yeah
it was just awful it was terrible yeah
you know you compare a gaming bar
anywhere else and you're like that dude
they've got
games yeah they got real like the way i
would describe meltdown is it's it's
basically like a unibar yeah but it was
but they charged more than the unibar
it was just this it was like a rundown
bar and like every single bar in london
that is even remotely interesting i feel
is sort of run down
unfortunately yeah because i don't know
the thing about pubs that
i i hate is that for some reason they
just seem so dark i don't know it's it's
everything i think what pups are you
going to man there's so many in london
that are so fun
anytime i go to like a pub styled bar
like
anywhere else the first thing i noticed
is man it's so bright in here
this is nothing like british pubs this
is nothing like british pubs at all are
you like going to the pubs that are like
down the alley like
just like like the proper like local
pubs because in the uk there's the pubs
that
anyone goes to and then there's the pubs
that have like the exact same 30 people
going to that yeah
and those are the depressing as [ __ ]
yeah i don't know most 90 percent of
weather spoons i'd say fit under that
category
yeah okay most weather spoons are
weather springs is a brand of pubs in
the uk it's just like this ultra treat
brand and you took me to one i did take
you to one i think
the reason people go there is because of
the very very cheap drinks and cheap
food that you use what was it like five
pounds for like a full course meal or
something
right you basically get like a full
course meal with an alcoholic drink for
like
seven pounds which is like nine dollars
um
in london in london which is a like in
london the drinks alone normally were
like
eight dollars which i'm probably people
in california are like oh that [ __ ]
like in the uk that's bear in mind where
i i grew up yeah
a drink that's over three pounds which
is like four dollars is like whoa yeah
yeah get a load of this guy yeah if
you're gonna pop in australia like for a
pint it's like nine bucks
yeah i mean where i the what the weather
spoons this is the cheap areas where i i
grew up it was like
their main selling point was like two
pound pints and sometimes
some of the special brews were like one
pound sixty wow so that's like
two dollars something for a pint yeah
you have no no wonder that
there's like people are in there from
like 2 p.m until 9 00 p.m just like dead
getting their money's worth
yeah cause like to me pubs are just the
place where you pre-drink before you
actually go out to the establishment you
want to go to right that's that's that's
how i see it whereas
with uh izakayas i can [ __ ] stay
there from the
beginning of the night at the end of the
night yeah you don't feel pressured to
leave and you normally have like
they're normally cordoned off decently
well when you feel like it's just you
and your mates
yeah whereas sometimes the pubs having
to see everyone around you is a little
like oh my god it's busy
that's one thing i don't like about i
guess like uk style pubs and there are a
few
of those in japan as well um there's
this place called the hub
which i'm sure you boys are aware don't
go to there by the way because
it's like it's like going into a uk pub
but in japan so why the [ __ ] writer
okay that's a little bit brighter i've
heard though if you're a foreigner and
you really want to pick up
some people who are really into
foreigners oh yeah yeah yeah they're
probably there because they know that
foreigners go there if you have the
yellow fever but can't be bothered to go
the traditional route
go to the hub yeah yeah but like shibuya
you'll be fine yeah but like
like every time i go into a hub it's
just well first of all it's like
99 foreigners it's also very depressing
it's also very depressing because it's
it's
it's like kind of structured like what
i'm saying right it's structured like a
uk pub where like the seats are kind of
sporadic and then
everyone is standing around you so you
just feel really claustrophobic yeah i
don't mind standing and drinking
sometimes standing is fun
i don't know like i need a table yeah
there definitely needs
needs to be a table there where i can
leave my drink if i'm just like standing
in a corner which
sometimes on like a friday or saturday
night in england where some
pubs are crowded and you just have to
stand there in the middle of the floor
just with your mates i'm just like
this is this is not the vibe i want to
go my legs hurt i want to sit down
like the thing i like about izakayas is
that you're always sitting down you have
your own
sanctioned corner where you can just sit
and talk to your mates and it's just
like
the perfect kind of catch-up vibe that i
look for when i just want to
just chill with my mates and just so
cheap like you can go to any izakaya
here and like the most you'll pay for a
beer is like what like 400 yen
maybe that's like a pretty that's that's
an expensive one yeah well i'm saying
like the max you'll pay
normally you pay between 200 and 300 yen
for like
a beer which is like two three dollars i
went to an izakaya though whereas 50 yen
beers
what's the point 50 a.m how do we even
compete there's one thing that doesn't
make sense to me right
is that sometimes it's cheaper to drink
in an izakaya than it is to go to a
family martial
kombini and buy like a can of beer buy a
can of beer
which like can you imagine if that was
the case in the uk like if going to
tesco's it's more expensive than going
to your local weather spoons
i'm just like nobody nobody would drink
at home yeah everyone would just be out
constantly drinking
i think the uk economy would just stop
yeah i think i think it would
the country would fail